yeah so so basically I think maybe my
colleague is used to debating perhaps
some certain Christians and
what-have-you
I'd like to think that perhaps we were a
slightly different breed in terms of our
approach or logical approach I don't
think he dressed actually what I said
and I think straw man my argument but
for example I'll give example so I never
said everything that begins to exist has
a cause I never used that because the
you can always say well how do you know
everything does begin to exist and that
would require empirical verification
which is what I never that's why I never
said it in the first place I merely
posited that ultimately and I don't know
where the where this ultimately is I
just said ultimately there will be a
course I don't know how old the universe
is maybe we've been through a couple of
you know six or seven big bangs and big
Crunch's and until getting to this point
of course universe is everything that
exists I merely said that at some point
it has to start somewhere because an
infinite regress would mean there would
be no change no creation nothing and the
same for things like what matter is
composed of I never made an assumption
that it is quantum vacuum energy or
super strings which a lot a lot of
scientists now doubt the idea of super
string theory a bit of fantastical but
but I just posit those those two let's
say whatever you want the question or
can always be asked what are they made
out of what are they made out of
if their attributes come from what's
something what they made out of for
example then what can you eat what can
they made out of until you get to the
point where there must be something
that's fundamental have fundamental
substratum that supports all we at his
existence
and if it's fundamental and it's
necessary then it wouldn't be limited
and it would be self sufficient because
it wouldn't require anything prior to it
or underneath it or further more
fundamental than itself so this is a
common the arguments I made but I guess
just to kind of reframe this discussion
in terms of what I mean by atheism or
why I'm I mentioned the term atheism
you're right atheism isn't a belief but
I posited that it carries a necessary
corollary something attached to it which
is if you don't believe in God's
existence not that you may be just you
is just your default know if you
don't believe it's God's existence that
means that your worldview does not
require you to posit God to explain
things and I'm really posited that
reality imposes certain problems if you
want to keep God out of that discussion
because ultimately you can't explain
cause matter specificity or limit into
fine light things and my explanation
isn't one where I've known sigh know
stuff because I've observed it is that
God is the only explanation to avoid
self-contradictions and that's pretty
much it like like I'm saying if we take
two and we add two I know that this will
equal 4 because taking the premises the
conclusion must follow so likewise I
know that the premises are the existence
of finite things that's the premises so
I know that eventually at some point it
must follow that there must be a
beginning point a creating point a start
point and a fundamental substratum that
supporting all things even though I
don't know where there is where the
boundary of that is that's my our key
much you could you put that into the dr.
fool in the deductive form while I'm so
two plus two equals four is a deductive
form it's a premise and a conclusion
it's not deductive form to say there is
matter and matter must have a beginning
what's the what's the deductive argument
there well for example well it's the
avoidance of contradiction because plane
so if I was to say two plus two equals
six right and six meaning what we what
we conventionally unsend six to be we
know that was wrong because of
contradiction so my point was that if
you were to say well before before this
point in time there was an infinite
number of moments or movements I would
say we would never reach this point in
time because it would be a contradict
the I think you know what I'm saying the
you're trying to say you want us to say
everything that begins to exist has a
call no that's not necessarily the kalam
that's what I'm going what I'm saying is
that if you the reason why you can say
the two plus two equals six is false is
because you're right at least to a
logical contradiction the reason for
that is because it's essentially a
logically valid argument with premises
and conclusions and you can identify
exactly how it contradicts you can put
it into a truth table and show that yes
it's tables precisely is it is a
tautology in you and you can prove that
deductively
there's no can you highlight precisely
what the premises are and the
conclusions are of your argument here so
it doesn't because it does if you're
going to say that it leads to
contradictions if you don't agree with
it well it does because in the form of
an infinite regress is basically saying
that there was no beginning and yet
we're explaining although there was no
cause and we're explaining the cause of
things were explained in the beginning
of things all explaining movement so
there was no first movement but there is
movement so it creates a contradiction
in terms because in essence we rely on a
pre-existing state or a pre-existing
conditions of movement and yet
ultimately there is no doesn't you're
saying there is no beginning to this
pre-existing thing there's just eternal
an eternal chain that there is no start
and we therefore it's the same as say
nothing actually ironically to prove
that we require so I've got one
statement too that can kind of summarize
it for you anything susceptible to
additional subtraction cannot be
infinite okay
okay so that's it doesn't need to be a
deductive three-stage deduction that
makes it right so now I'm just given one
statement he what he's saying is that if
you have an infinite thing and you add
to it
then there's the absurdity of adding to
an infinite physical quantitative thing
so you'd have to disprove that statement
now we've made a statement anything
susceptible to additional subtraction
cannot be right cannot be infinite so in
order for you to to prove your infinite
regress if you wanted to prove it you
have to prove or you have to show how
it's demonstrably possible for something
to have infinity as it as a quality as
well as addition and subtraction there
as well no idea so then you can't really
make anything I don't know but I'm not
making a claim that's a thing so then
why I'm having this discussion because
I'm opposing your claims what you can't
oppose your claim is that it the all
claim is that it requires it and I'm
just asking you why that's I'm saying
anything that is logically the idea that
it is logically necessary to have
causation although they call they can't
be an infinite regress no no I've just
said the wife sees this
the same alignment anything is
susceptible to addition or subtraction
cannot be quantitative quantitatively
infinite yes you have to you if you're
reducing that you have to disprove that
how is it physically mathematically or
otherwise how is it possible to have a
quantifiable infinite which is
susceptible to additional subtract
that's we have to do I've just made the
claims it seems brief that's true and
you failed to do the answer the answer
the answer is that you're right like
these things are required okay according
to the laws of logic and physics that
are predicated on the existence of the
universe and we're talking about the
universe why is it pretty clear on the
existence of universe because can you
prove it well no okay so why it's a
possibility right
no no no it's an active claim which then
it's not this is amazing possibly but
you know it's not a possibility if it's
possibly true no it's not possible true
why is it not possible because if the
universe of possible existence then it
cannot explain the existence of other
possible existences if if there is a
necessary did you gather Jonas on the
page yes I'm asking if there's no you
can you just at first this one friend do
it if there is a necessary being or
occurrence and that entails and which is
what you admit and that M and that
entails yet another occurrence no it
doesn't intend if it does if I may just
say I think the confusion is firstly I
don't think all things require putting
into logical syllogisms yes I think it's
necessary do it I'm saying that it does
when you're making contrary propositions
you don't doesn't a sentence could say
that this sentence is false it creates a
contradiction within the sentence
without it being a logical syllogism you
like that that maybe I'm merely pointing
out that there are ultimately only two
possibilities to two basic anything that
you might observe which is finite limit
they don't what have you which is either
it was it was the result of something
more fundamental than it or something
with that that's right that it's prior
to it and if you ask well what was prior
to any anything what is more fundamental
to anything either it's something that's
like itself as insight finite limited as
well or something not the case not
finite not limited so I'm saying if we
go down the pathway of just constantly
insisting on there's a
continual chain prior to this existence
of finite limited things nothing would
exist because that would cause an
infinite regress fallacy and thereby the
contradiction is manifest as opposed to
ultimately at some point saying well
actually you know what at some point I
don't know where but at some point there
was a beginning of there was something
that was not finite where bride doesn't
have limitations and just to kind of
justify to you the limitations requires
explanation something doesn't have
limitations doesn't require expenditure
but there's no limits for it to be
there's nothing to create its limits for
it to be explained by something else oh
it's still so far as explanation simple
observation if you say God created all
the next obvious question of course is
who created God and Colin nobody has
given please let me finish and the
second one is as I say you are talking
the language of certainty what we have
learned in the course of my lifetime is
that the origins of the universe have
been pushed further and further back in
time it's a fascinating study I don't
pretend to understand more than the
average man on the street about it but
to say that we clearly understand the
nature of creation seems to me extremely
arrogant and to pretend that you can
speak with certainty about something
like that I think is good admire they're
not justified well I think it's a little
arrogant to actually dismiss what we
actually said because we never actually
claimed that we know every tiny particle
in this universe or how big it is or
where it begun we never actually said
that so eat it I'm just saying yesterday
just saying that it shows that you
weren't listening to what we were saying
and some people might say that's a bit
arrogant - um well I'm saying is very
simply this creation or causation or
whatever you want to cause it is to
limit something to defy this limitation
that when you draw a circle drawing a
limitation so limitations require
explanation but if something has no
limitation then there's nothing that
requires it to be determined cuz it has
no there's not there's no boundaries
that existed it is it is fundamentally a
positive necessary being and say it
doesn't require any I didn't say
necessary I said but that's the opposite
of limited
no because limitations require
explanation right not not black they're
off and limitation as opposed to what
what was the opposition not not being
limited and what is something what is
something that's not limited well it's
necessary because if it's not necessary
that it's limited what's your definition
of necessary cuz you keep using it
incorrectly what's your understanding or
necessary existence well you know you
were talking about contingent things
it's the audience the opposite of that
so something like can you give us
something that cannot have been
differently and there's no explanation
for it outside of itself
well I suppose okay so can you can you
can you tell us how they can be a world
with no necessary existence well who
says well you said we're living in a
world of possible or you said that we
have to claim that we're living in a
world of possible existences you do you
agree that there could be a explain that
do you accept that there is a necessary
existence I would say that yes then
that's good that doesn't have to that
does not it does not have to be there
for us a necessary existence is
something which is this is the perfect
couldn't be another way explains
everything else that's our definition of
everything else because without this
necessary couldn't be any other way
Alex all contingent things depend upon
it yes
give me an example the contingent thing
and it's this come how is it contingent
because it could have otherwise not been
in existence you know speaking to a
determinist fun yeah okay so what is the
tourism so if if you said your and your
thing sorry what the terminal yeah you
in yes let me ask you questions whether
you - later but it will make sense go
ahead if P entails Q go he is necessary
yes is Q necessary no it's not no no no
it's not just doesn't have to be if
necessary so look let me explain why
what we're doing here is we've said that
these dependent contingent things as
you're defining them do you accept that
this cup could have otherwise not been
in existence no so okay this that's what
to tell it isn't it wasn't do you
believe in the determinism yes and you
said in your you said in your speech in
your thing you know
from nothing you said that determinism
comes from the necessary existence right
yes
48 minutes in you said that one
necessarily leads from the other in
other words determinism leads from
necessary distance yes or no you said
you said determinism leads from
necessary existence okay I think we were
talking about a different thing no no
you said this and I can show you know
you said the University of assisted is
hardly a semantic pool in scoring
exercises it's not anything different by
what you're no problem but you said this
you said and you said matter
you said determinism comes from the
necessary existence what did I mean by
that two days ago the guy asked you is
the universe would you agree with
Bertrand Russell that the universe just
is yeah and you replied and said yeah
the fact that universal necessary
existence the I would agree with that in
the first instance and then he said how
would that tie in with determinism you
then said determinism follows from is
that which follows the term doesn't
follows from the necessary existence
right I tried remember I was taught so I
was I was the person was debating with
the local camera but it's yeah making
the cat he was making the case with the
contingency argument I'm saying that
there are contingent things in the
universe and therefore he was using that
reason that there's a god and I said
that if that were the case yes that
necessary existence the condition would
follow from that I was making my case
okay so I did agree than it does it
listen Alex I didn't say that it will
agree with you on that point so this is
the thing you agree with us on more
points than you think you agree with us
on you believe in a necessary existence
which explains everything else necessary
existence be careful as you said and
necessary existence you are you
retracting it I said that the are you
attracting the universe there's not one
unified necessary you said that the
universe wasn't necessarily the universe
follows a necessary causal chain okay so
that is that is there I'm you said
hold on you said the universe is a
necessary existence and then you said
determinism follows from that
now I'm saying that if I said that and I
meant what you think I meant by I seen
yes I retract it but to attract it I
don't
I think what it is alex is that you
people can go and look at other stuff so
you're very good at making arguments
against things I used to believe in oh
nothing's even it because okay now it's
perfect no it's important because if you
changing you and I have money and I
haven't yet that's the only reason why
you've changed your okay thank you
after that I was wanted so they do
creative god yeah well we have to
actually ask the question why does
anything need creation in the first
place right it's a more fundamental
question yeah so I mean I could take
this clock but I usually sometimes I
just take a stone or something and I say
how do you know that this actually thing
was create or required it to be quite
creation so if this thing was let's say
eternal or let's say uncreated then why
is it in this particular shape form and
so on so forth that it didn't to choose
if something was uncreated and nothing
determined its limitations then it
wouldn't have limitations which is my
point
so therefore it's it's it's kind of
ridiculous to argue that God requires
creation when he has no limits that
require and defined by anything to be
defined by will determined by something
else and that's why we know that
anything is created it's only because it
has limitations how long do you think
God's being around for eternity well
okay what I'll say is that they you know
God is outside of time so there's no
there's no pre-existent time before him
right he's the beginning how do you know
but but I you know what that kind of
just you mention you mentioned in your
your presentation I just want to just be
touching it before we do anything else
which is you said that Islam is
terrified of of a people professing
atheism all right again I think that's I
don't know what experience you've had
maybe with from reading European history
books but I said I suppose you should
read books from about Mesopotamia and
understand I mean that's like if I may
just finish I'll let you respond so the
Prophet Mohammed has had a famous debate
with a Bedouin atheist right there was
no intolerance there the bit did Betty
when a professor became Muslim but there
was no intolerance just because the guy
initially profess to be atheist um Abu
Hanifah famous classical scholar
in medieval Iraq Baghdad actually had
public open-air debates with atheists
presumably there's atheists were living
in Baghdad time to actually be invited
to open-air debates and no one killed
them all was intolerant to them at all
whatsoever and when you say Oh Islamist
is terrified of atheists I just want to
say something you're not special we
encounter polytheists we encounter
Christian tear Trinitarians we encounter
Zoroastrians for our history and from
our perspective you're all arguing
exactly the same thing which is somehow
the the finite thing is this is also
infinite eternal and we don't really we
don't really see you as different
actually you're just a just another yeah
yeah it's not a flavor of ice cream that
we are basically encountering so I don't
don't make yourself out to be what else
more special than you are from the our
perspective and as for their issue of
tolerance of atheists I think you should
question your founders of your very
ideology which pervades the West
liberalism john locke in his letter on
toleration argued that you should
tolerate different christian sects
protestants typically but not yes
because you can't trust what they say
they don't believe in any higher moral
value or then mainly what is expedient
Rousseau made also the same argument and
some people say that under the current
you could say atheistic idea as opposed
to the natural rights arguments of John
Locke but the event of my arguments of
utilitarianism really morality is only
based on expediency and then people's
rights are based on whether it's
expedient to the state to even tolerate
your right so that it's not related to
debate itself but the guy brought it up
and it's really disingenuous to bring up
in that kind of debate yes yes are you
suggesting that someone like Socrates
was a deeply immoral man no I'm not
saying it I'm saying your latest you
seem to be implying no no John Locke
said that you that you can't look lost a
theater but if all the differences other
things the things which are well view a
bit based upon which are the
philosophies of these men we can say
that those areas of their philosophies
were wrong John Locke said some pretty
egregious things the Annihilus how can
you say anything the differences we'll
get to that the difference it's not
something that you're wrong right I
think I actually want
and don't believe the difference is the
difference is that you can't do the same
thing in this undergrowth so when there
is something immoral when there is
something immoral in the basis it when
there is something immoral that comes
from somebody who founded the worldview
that we believe in and something else
unrelated Li that he said that no longer
applies was wrong can you prove you
something we can say that we disagree
with or do we have to we can say that we
disagree what he had to do the same so
can you do the same thing you're making
Annapolis immoralities in the Quran you
can't make the same look we have just
allowed you to speak and there were many
times I could have interjected and asked
you similar questions and you're making
your to cooperate fallacy and you smart
enough to know it you can't just turn
around it's your son's very question for
being a moral nihilus especially since
I'm not one anymore oh you've changed
your mind yes
that's all what what statement the ones
that you said you're more right now
listen what do you think moral
subjective isn't mentally and means to
me what do you think you'll say you're
saying you can't say this because you're
a moral subject to this in tomorrow yeah
you're making a moral clip your father
mojo does what is moral subject yeah so
you don't have a victim or ally it's not
for it's not fixed it's not true or
false
despite human thoughts or convictions
that morality is it's true so it's only
first class yeah my questions had asked
one question then he can answer it my
question is he's made it very clear on
his public profile that this man is does
not believe an object of morality why
and how can you say this in one breath
and then starting passing moral
judgments which are based on liberalism
can you explain how a theism accounts
for that or how it doesn't I say that's
a to call a palace it's not a different
place I see you as well it's simply
saying well you do this - so who are you
to speak that's not not doing it we are
working on it your worldview your
worldview claims that morality is
objective and your worldview has
objective moral statements like the ones
I've highlighted it's your job to prove
yeah that those can be coherent with
objective morality God is all-knowing
God so that's what we believe anything
God says is all anything God says is
more yes okay refute that please I don't
need to know you do it that's why I'm
not trying to change your mind
okay I'm kind of talk for the audience
and if you want to find moral precepts
within Islam that they disagree with
they have to disagree what if you have
an all-knowing agency as you have said
and
if God says something is moral then it
is moral as that's what I say yeah and
so if the people here this evening
disagree with the moral precepts of this
utilization of Islam so let's talk about
that unless absolutely how do you know
what God said well okay here to go back
to our argument I said that we've said
that we have revelations of 4-time the
final revelation is the Quran as a
falsifiability test I gave you four
things preservation intimate ability
contradictions and I also taught you
about predictions of the Quran and
Sunnah now in order for you to say that
the Quran is false you have to falsify
it like a scientist would have to
falsify theory for in order for them to
say that that is wrong now if you can't
produce any evidence for that then
really you can only remain agnostic on
the issue how do you make one Sasori how
do you know that the words contained in
the Quran were the words that were
actually supposed to have been spoken to
the habit by the angel Gabriel supposing
that any of those in the modern world
can leave it yeah okay so first and
foremost with regards to morality it's
actually completely irrelevant in this
debate concerning when we're discussing
explanation of reality if you don't
believe in objective morality then
there's nothing to compare the morality
of Islam with right just say that just
sort of discordant with it yes right so
I think it's a massive red herring and I
think I think that friend of yours will
talk about a few fallacies concerning
bringing up in the first place you have
to first present to us objective right
imagery and then compare it to Islam's
morality in sight there's that they
don't they don't fit you can't and
that's my point
and also the fact that you say well if
we don't like some morality in the back
in the past or some basis or for just
affirm rights in the past we can change
it well that's what's scary because in
modern was a 21st century Europe and of
what one 20th century Europe need i say
more
people thought that morality of people's
protections of rights and things were no
longer convenient for the nation that
the nation's security and then they
prejudicially in a persecute certain
minorities because it was no longer
beneficial from their estimation and
there's no objective basis to argue
against other than you say what i
diapered see don't like or find it
distasteful no he did so that that is
actually scary that you don't have
objective
because there's no actual promise of of
Rights that you can actually under right
now as for the well no well yes I mean
they're wrong I mean you're asking a
question or you just okay the restaurant
statement look the subjectivity of
morality doesn't lie at the level of the
act itself it lies at the level of the
motivations I can say to somebody like
we I I am a psychological headedness in
the same way that nil was I can say - I
know what people's motivations are
ultimately speaking and I and there are
objective facts to be known about how to
achieve a goal so it's not a case more
subjective as Mills mill demands for all
objective is immoral immoral I said I'm
a psychological utilitarian on missiles
harian like John Stuart Mill not just a
utilitarian ok well I hope the audience
can notice the difference in the level
of interjection here like I'm trying to
really listen to what you have to say
but you've got to let me respond okay
good
psychological utilitarianism means that
we can know what people's motivations
are and I think we can there are
objective things to be known about how
to achieve those goals
if somebody thinks that something is
right and I think it's wrong it's not a
case of throw your hands up in the air
and say it's everybody's opinion that's
not what moral subjectivism is that's
confusing moral subjectivism with moral
relativism that's not what we're doing
those are not the same thing that can
respond all right so Mill in Chapter
four of his book on utilitarianism he
actually gave us the exact way of
identifying what he called the principle
of utility yes and through that he
talked about desirability and how when
you see that something is desirable for
someone then that is it that is an
evidence that is something which sport
to be done okay hold on you can check
I've just given you a reference yes I am
because I saw all the rooms of the title
the title I didn't say the audience
conditions are not rejecting I said the
owners can notice the disparity in it
those actions are needed in the
interaction here is the title of that
chapter there's a reason why the times
my chapter yeah it's not the true
computer latarian it is it is not it's
like the title here's a book the title
of that chapter is the kinds of proofs
to which utilitarianism is susceptor the
title of the chapter is proof of your
telephone it's not you get you can check
it now again it is the types of a proof
that utilitarian is which is acceptable
to John Stuart Mill wrote the book
himself you can get the
for motor stones now everyone in the
area can google it yes it's actually the
title is proof of utility our chapter 4
that's what people call it that's not
what mill wrote no who calls earth at
its height mill milk no milk you saying
mill doesn't call it the proof
utilitarian that's what its title he
avoids it he doesn't listen name of the
chapter mice and not the name of the
Japanese shut up yeah if you'd like to
okay so no one's got utilitarianism it's
a wooden why it's the reason okay so
just to concede a zero is not movers oak
a I can see that point of view if he's
right I can see that's right because I
don't care if you're right or wrong
about that it's in the thing that
matters is the point that he was making
and the point that he was making it that
you can't prove utilitarianism because
he's a moral nihilist in a sense but he
said that there are certain proves to
which is some prove it why main ok so
because you can't prove that the point
in the middle maybe so is also subject
to the point of the mill made with a
visible thing which you brought up is
that the only evidence we have that
something is visible is that it can be
seen that's what you said now we we
can't prove okay this is usable and if
we can use the same to understand more
okay it's not one thing it's an end up
why one thing for someone who said that
there are many things that you know you
don't know in the universe and things
that you can't presume yes for you to
claim that you now know people's
motivations with the same kind of
certainty enough to make it to derive
some objective moral system yes it's
somewhat of a contradiction there
because everyone's motivations might be
unique or different yes unknowable to
you anyway certainly we never understand
the viewpoint of a psychopath forces
that's right who has the inability to
empathize yeah the study of course but
to make a claim that basically that you
can understand everyone's motivations or
there is some kind of unique template of
motivations that all human beings
subscribe to or can fit into is really
convicting what you said earlier one
saying that you don't actually know or
you don't make claims to know things
which you don't directly about I make I
make those I also didn't say
I do it on the last question I open up -
I do I do make more I'll see that that's
not a problem I never said that I didn't
I also didn't say that I don't make
moralities it didn't I also didn't say
that you have to see things to be able
to prove them oh ok so are the
illusionary food
I would agree with that statement on
right I'm agreement I'm still waiting
for an answer to my question of how you
can possibly be sure that what are
supposed to be the words spoken by God
or rather by the angel Gabriel pointed
out to Muhammad are actually the words
spoken if indeed they were spoken at all
okay so a couple days ago I presented a
lecture on how do we know Islam is true
when there's so many different let's say
conflicting or competing belief systems
in essence from every aspect from the
Islamic concept of God being a main
issue which is what my presentation was
trying to focus on the Islamic concept
of God is almost completely unique to
Islam with the possible exceptions of
variations of Judaism and philosophers
who've you know reflected upon the
possibilities of what could exist and
what create all existence and they've
all come to the same conclusion just
like good old the Greek Gunnarsson often
is that they must be an ultimate craters
infinite and he's unlike creative things
nothing is a famous Greek philosopher
who believed that if he rejected
polytheism and rejected idols that look
like human beings saying if a cow had a
God it wouldn't make the the gods to
look like a cows so he didn't he was an
atheist he just rejected polytheism and
so we would basically kind of siloed
that view but there's something very
specific question yeah about yes what
the angel Gabriel is supposed to have
said just to Muhammad how can you
possibly know how can anybody possibly
know that that was actually what
happened oh yeah I'm late and if I would
let me just finish my point which is
Islam is basically if you when I
encountered it I encountered it and I
took it as a hypothesis for how to
explain the reality as one possible
hypothesis after looking at different
belief systems including or lack thereof
and let's say
mystic positions and belief system
naturalism or materialism communism and
such and such I basically you know found
contradictions and things that didn't
make sense and it kind of almost had a
process of elimination that Islam was
the only one left that actually didn't
suffer an eternal conditions both
compared to the observable reality as
well as within itself and that's very
tough thing too it's a very tall order
to actually achieve if you're not
explaining what everything quite
literally everything so oh and caveat
not the particularity zuv things like
you know how quarks and bosons in case
you actually say oh I don't you're
claiming to explain everything
no but what I am what I notice is that
Islam was the only one left and then
after further investigation after I
thought maybe it could have been a
different way maybe if one particularly
silent auction didn't exist or if it was
a different way and I realized that that
produces contradictions so the point
that I came to the conclusion that Islam
was the only possible explanation to
explain reality which is why I was very
thrilled to do this debate in the first
place
but without going to things like the you
know hell's existence and all this other
stuff the main key selling point users
who say of Islam of the hypothesis of
Islam except in reality was its concept
of God which is almost virtually unique
to itself and it's just rationally
consistent and coherent I didn't ask you
about Islam's concept of God I asked you
very specifically about how you can
possibly know that the concept of God
whatever it is that emerges from the
Quran can have been dictated to Muhammad
by the angel Gabriel I take it therefore
that you cannot answer that question
thank you well it's kind of like the
equivalent kind of challenge or you'll
say me now we can discuss how do we know
the mess the messenger that related the
message is how do we know from from
analysis of that day it's accurate but I
want to just to kind of that's what I
like to know I know I know and I want to
do it kind of a different angle to
answer that question which is what got
me into Islam in the first place was not
very different there let me finish sir
well go me into Islam in the first place
wasn't me
looking at the claims or trying to
go back in the time machine to find out
if the program existed of the angel
Gabriel came to him I looked at the
message itself and the consistency of
the message itself with the universe I
came again led me to a conclusion that
they both come from the same author and
that's why I became Muslim in other
words you can't possibly know the
audience